thanks for doing this yeah I really
appreciate it guys don't tickle my nips
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the don't laugh challenge
now I've done this two times before but
these guys are actually my inspiration
for doing this in the first place so
they have videos of this over on their
channel up a link in the description but
now we're gonna do the don't laugh
challenge when we put some seltzer water
in our mouth so that's even worse when
it goes out of our nose and this time to
make it different touching is allowed
there are no rules there are no limits
it's just touching it's like the wild
west of the touching unclaimed territory
ready for the grab I'm pretty sure
that's just the Wild West it's the Wild
West
okay just like you so uh I I'm not gonna
go first he's not wearing his teammate
shirts to get all wet yeah neither of
them are actually change my shirt I have
open armpits you guys have easy access
to mine in I'm not in touch today I
don't want to stick my hands in yours
yeah after a full day of working out in
the hot Sun I'm not gonna touch a pit
stop
I got washed in the bath a lot of the
t.j.maxx
baby you can use this for games of edge
nice already don't game top edge the go
edge games
welcome to the edge games you're gonna
get I'm gonna start the tiger shirt it's
just like playing around alright three
two one when I was six years old I was
born with that face he already lost them
look anything knows it's like a bull hey
let me tell you a story real quick sure
what's the story okay so one time we
went into habit I have the habit you
remember that hamburger joint yeah and
Brian ordered a drink and you ordered a
drink
and she put down the cup the empty cup
is it burning ha ha ha oh my god the
hoses put down the empty cup and he
grabs the tip jar nose 37 seconds dude
Wow
I wash you're just building your wealth
what happened so basically what happened
was instead of taking his cut
he took the tip door and fill it up with
the ball get it back in there's money in
Horry ha ha ha ha you bet ok my defense
it was a fresh tip jar with only one
single bill in there it was a dollar
bill in a clear cop so every time we go
back to the habit I'm like hey this is
the guy that build up your tip jar of
water and they're like oh I'm gonna give
a qualm you know all the hose in your
mouth I just run my hands or you have a
37 3 2 1 now
oh that was not a full more I don't know
ok so let's think about what my right
there Oh
take a look like any hard ha ha ha ha he
wants a life so bad why don't you squirt
on me no he's not gonna let ok
Oh again to get the right one now oh
yeah how much did you buy oh my god I
just got a nice one oh yeah you know
what's gonna show up now fanfic of you
two together
oh why not mark you're cheatin up
through here he's doing it's leaking out
of your nose
do you even have a sense of humor he
doesn't pick one I believe me my
supposedly beautiful people
oh wow Vika so Paige broke my nose why
so it what you attacked with it I don't
know what is he doing
oh no you doing son you're getting yeah
why don't look at me you gonna put it up
what no point
it's leave no pointing it's lady stuff
let's try this again wait don't move in
sconces yes the spin on his glasses now
sucker
is that burning no like broke 158 O's I
gotcha New Year was legal oh really I
know I had to move it back in my throat
I wasn't swallowing as as is evident by
the volume I had to move it back cuz I
can't help you so much gas was being
built I had to stand out of why he sent
it through my nose oh I quit that was my
farts so much nip abuse yeah how other
body part abuse Brian was good what I
get pretty so much all over you touch
all over you wouldn't be the first time
one why are you looking at me with such
love wouldn't I think it's gonna phases
glasses all pieces yeah I'm like
naturally sexier when I 3 2 1
boink look more no no that's not even a
full oh no it's pretty regulation wanna
know how they cause Bulls to collect
their semen mmm dick is not gonna make
the stick an electric rod up their anus
and then they send electrical currents
good and it's called electro ejaculator
cool it no oh the gas is building oh
it's cause you check out this lab
well that made him what yeah oh yeah
shake his head good lad what I have to
touch you you have to omit any tickle
might have to that take no breathing
tickle how about a tenderness all these
leaky if I love the breathe then you're
sweet dude we don't breathing okay yeah
okay you've got some girthy shoulders
here they're really nice
you like him no I can't reach him Joey
touch him oh okay oh wait wait give me
that Ken Hulk give [ __ ] wait let's
get what you want turndown service
oh you think of Hulk wait forget
okay we're real things to month yet
let's get some fizzy action going on in
there what I'm allowed to touch that's
taking the top of his head you idiot
when you think of me I'm gonna hit me
mine into it Brian
shake is geez thank you this is the
first time I've done this to you oh
thank you hey come look huh stop you
can't block it dude you have to accept
it absolutely sir if you have to accept
it everyone cut you know [ __ ] oh oh
goochie goochie goo mmm we'll hold baby
what's the Hulk out of there in 212 he's
lovely that you swallow
I win not yet
hi my mouth feels so weird right okay
how are you no no no no come on don't
pretend like you took a lot are you
gonna time it yeah oh [ __ ] yeah go do
you remember my block with your mouth
puffed out like that you look like a big
mouse bath he's a big mouse bad ah
that's my speech impediment made you
laugh you're a horrible person already
great
three two one nobody even caught that he
said big mouse bad haha big mouse bath I
do it when it was coming out of my mouth
you didn't catch anything I got the time
it's going we're just not worried about
you right now we're having our own
conversation do you mind
Brian will you this Brian watch this
Brian OH
I know - listen working with my shake
yeah I'll do you full mouth full mouth
open up pulling out what all these
challenge I'm doing is so messy there
yeah that's right go yes you got a smell
mouthful dude Oh mouth Oh
what is that you said you got a snow
malkos it smell Wow
I said go and now you go home I'll
napple let me play that please your
smell muffled hey you got a big mouth
bass what that's look ready to say you
know what's got a smell Rumble did you
start the timer shooter here a smile
mouth bag nobama
ball mouth dude I met this girl I went
on a date with this girl one time she
had a bad case of Malmo I gotta tell you
that's a mall now you don't want to know
bro you've been around them all a lot
yeah kisses yeah hum dum AGGA Chewbacca
yeah nobody can talk about mouths
correctly oh yeah I'm like right all
right yes
hey hey give them the whole snaky [ __ ]
oh you won fair a TV show oh bugger lips
what's your vinegar ball no tiniest
mouth oh you got a small mouth oh yeah
you got my meme at home I have a small
mouth
you look desperate do you know you can
get it oh that's very funny I always
thought they were just the Photoshop
things that you made your thumb goes
into a small mouth all right man drink
it once he completes the full mouth
reception then he can what free oh come
on open up him he's got a cut above his
eye mmm-hmm wake up does a little makeup
a little shake up a little bit a boy see
how he have our little table you wanted
to do that again
you wanted to do he wanted what he
wanted to contort your lips contort
Kotori Allah make your lips look like oh
no Garth Brooks or something random oh
he does a good job the air vents from
his nice little air vents
it's called you not see how is he ever
going to a girl at a bar go he's opening
up his nighter but that's how I hit on
girls hey baby you got some nice
industrial says if not do anything man
what's your water drinking baby you're
fit to kill this Gotti teardrop zoom in
on this you ever see a you ever go to
girl and she's 9/10 knows my defenses
now it's mommy numb yeah
no don't [ __ ] team edge man oh yeah
I'm overshadowed by Cabezas new mesh
tour no spray on my face you can spray
on my face baby this world is Graham I'm
not baby spray on my face they get it
right open your mouth o mouse hole dude
now Valentin 44 you almost lost like
nine times here how is he doing how are
we releasing the pressure without the
pressure shouldn't the bubbles be going
into your nasal Cassidy okay
you're laughing cheese or full-bore he's
giving it in the home get enough in your
mouse hole your new navel cavity what he
said Cassidy Cassy Butch Cassidy in the
no chance
yeah to 12 from 12 oh man I owe that
much do you have to get like five
minutes you know what it is
the doctor told him when he was younger
that he had very elastic
elasticized rink up dude his his cheeks
are very elastic
you know fresh I just expanded like a
chipmunks my cheeks are not elastic yeah
yours weren't going to Sag little late
for all the beans get the whole hand in
their feet all the being livings in
amount of money marbles go on the wrong
the beam my feet overall the beans this
is for all the marbles my video I said
for all beans to serving beans every
we're actually in have any no your
secular
it's true dude it was this little uh
yeah you're pretending to drink why were
the way the baby actually drinking all
right go
no third it's all at once you fills up
his like what you doing go Joey I'll
watch this you want to see some know you
needle and wanna make something funny
you want to see something even funnier
mmm-hmm I'll tell ya good I got it
didn't I thought it was gonna work
honestly I thought I'm sure you did Joey
let's do this Joey I'm gonna speak so
you me a Center give me a sense to say
really quick okay uh whose what's that
your mouth oh it's a couch Joe
the would friend you here as you click
oh what's that it to go you friends got
a big mouth okay well is a while ago
there's a little bit anyways alright
Karen you got last place oh I win why
does that make you win yeah I'm gonna
bother to Talia yeah we didn't have that
I was pretty close this first place yeah
you guys can tally it in the comments
below if you'd like
thanks everybody for watching and check
out team edge over on their channel
links are in the description below
thanks for joining us sorry for making a
mess so thanks again everybody and as
always we'll see you in the next video
time to eat nachos
ba-bye you interrupted it again at the
end of every video I didn't know you did
an outro you know I thought he said the
bull head will sing Google video I
thought that was it no I bye bye bye
it's my thing this is my thing it's
Matthias there now say bye bye bye bye